- You guys are in for a real treat.
We do have an opening act, though.
- Yes, we do,
and their name is
- [Both] Try Guys!
- [Try Guys] Hi, Anime Expo!
- Cosplay!
What is cosplay?
- Cosplay originates in Japan.
It's costume play, and it basically is
dressing up as a favorite character.
- We've never done cosplay, before.
I get to be an Asian lady.
Umm.
- Anime Expo invited us to
perform at their masquerade
in front of thousands of people.
- Cosplay is like Halloween
every day at Disneyland.
- Exactly.
- Christmas can suck my (beeps).
Thanksgiving can get
(beeps) in the (beeps),
because Halloween is the best,
so cosplay is gonna be amazing.
- We don't know what
characters we're being.
We've never watched anime.
We've never cosplayed.
We have no idea what
our sketch is gonna be.
This is a nightmare.
- If anyone's interested,
they should at least try it.
- Well, we're the Try Guys,
and we're gonna try it.
- [Voiceover] The Try Guys
Try Cosplay, Episode One.
The Try Guys Watch Anime.
- We should go to Anime
Expo as anime characters.
- Yeah, I would suggest it, just because
you might get more people appreciating it.
- I don't know much about anime.
- I know that they have
huge beads of sweat,
and they fall down
anytime something happens.
- The one thing I know about anime
is that everyone looks like Eugene.
- That's racist.
- Not because he's Asian, but
because of his fantastic hair.
- Kamekameha!
Plink!
- Hey, we're here with FUNimation.
We're gonna talk to
some voice actors, here.
- All of our work's
kind of been vindicated,
because it was like, "Oh,
anime's a niche thing."
- 'Cause we both got into
this like in the late 90's
when there wasn't much
anime, if any, on television.
- Anime fans did not get enough credit
by the general mainstream,
which they are starting to, now.
- So, since the other Try Guys
are really unfamiliar with
anime, I picked some scenes
from series that are really iconic,
because we need to figure
out which characters
we're gonna go as.
- [Ned] Whoa,
that's a big muscle man.
- [Keith] Eww.
- [Ned] He's steaming out of his mouth.
- I can see his butt.
- Look at that ass.
That's a Ned butt.
- Is she paralyzed by fear?
- That's a boy.
- Who are all these short, naked people?
- Yeah, I like that they're naked.
It's very arousing.
- What?
(all yelling)
- Oh, my god, all that dad's blood!
- Come on, Japan!
- This animation is gorgeous.
- It is, it's beautiful.
- This is better than most movies.
- When we're talking about cosplay,
we're talking about badass weapons,
these guys got some
- [Ned] They've got cool
- [Zach] badass weapons.
- [Ned] weapons.
It's like Game of Thrones, but animated.
- Anime's like, "Hey, here's
your favorite character.
Sorry!"
- I mean, Keith kinda got
that Titan look, though.
- I really do look like
some of those Titans.
- [Keith] They know that
alchemy isn't real, right?
- [Eugene] Well, in this
world, alchemy is real.
- You cannot make gold
out of just any old thing.
- That is the opening
sequence of this anime.
- Why are they always blowing up moms?
- Anime is just people losing
their legs and moms dying.
- Why are their costumes all
Revolutionary War period?
- I've noticed in a lot of anime shows,
they're inspired by
different time periods.
- Is the bald man with the cute
baby hair, he's the bad guy?
You know, villains are
always trying to stab people
in the dick, and then they just get away
so their dicks don't get stabbed.
- I thought watching
cartoons was gonna be fun,
but it's just making me really sad.
- It's crazy how anime can
jump from something so serious
and traumatic to something
fun and goofy and light.
- Yeah, I guess we're
having a good time again.
- I totally get why you would
want to emulate these people,
because they're very strong.
They're, like, heroic.
It would be fun to be
- [Eugene] They look cool.
- It would be fun to
pretend you are this person.
- The fight choreography in
this show is great, though.
- Every movement has a
specific sound in anime,
which is really fun.
(mimics weird sound effects)
- Is there a word for that sound?
- React.
- [Guy on Left] React.
- [Eugene] It's a react sound?
- It's called a react, yes.
They'll call us up and say,
"You have 125 lines and 800 reacts."
- Would you mind giving us
a really good react each?
(screaming)
- That's every time I make toast
and the toast comes
before I'm ready for it.
- I try to do the fight
reacts in real time,
so like the (Japanese-sounding grunts).
- 'Cause apparently, in Japan,
when people turn their head,
they make a sound like this.
(scoffing)
(mimics scoffing)
- You'll probably learn
about the character
as you make them.
I recommend picking a character you like,
because the cosplay creation
process can be hard.
- [Ned] They know how to start a show.
These credits are off the hook!
- Yeah, it's like anime
openings are like music videos.
- Yeah.
Wait, this is still the credit sequence?
- [Zach] Yeah!
- [Eugene] Yeah!
- His hair is terrific.
What's his secret?
Maybe it's Maybelline?
♫ Maybe it's anime ♫
"You like my book.
"I see you've written
a lot of names down."
- What I think Japan does,
and it's really cool,
is that they're able to
tell dramatic, adult stories
through animation.
Like, it's weird to have a main character
who I really don't like.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- I would much rather watch L's story
than Light's story.
- [Ned] Yeah.
- He's always sitting like this.
- I feel like I'm ready to poop.
- I was gonna say "poop,"
yeah.
- [Zach] Yep.
This one's cool, but I don't
see anything for cosplay, here.
I say next.
♫ Revolutionary girl
♫ I'm a revolutionary girl ♫
- What does Utena mean?
That just reminds me of a UTI.
(chuckles)
- That's her name, Ned.
- How old is this character?
Can we lust after this character?
- No, they're all pretty much
between 13 and 18.
- [Zach] Then why are they
showing so many legs?
- God, those men have gorgeous locks!
- This is like our one chance to have hair
as good as Eugene's.
- We get fancy hair.
You're stuck with your
stupid, perfect hair.
- [Ned] Yeah.
- Why is their school
upside-down?
- [Ned] Wait, what?
- It's a metaphor for how
upside-down life is as a kid.
- Ah.
- She's just getting
the sword that resides
within the princess's body.
- [Ned] Wow.
That was very sexual.
- My high school was nothing like this.
- My high school was
nothing like Utena's, right?
- I was in band.
- How many American cartoons can you name
that have a girl that has a
sort of kind of romantic
relationship with another girl
and is basically dressing
in boys' clothes?
- Dora the Explorer.
- Like with their anime, Japan is
all about empowering people that our media
does not empower at all.
- And they were doing it way before,
and in children's cartoons,
they were doing it.
- We still don't do this.
- I've always said in press
interviews I'm so honored
to be a part of something that brings
so many people together.
You look at the crowd, here.
You got every age, every
ethnicity, both sexes,
all sexualities, all
political affiliations,
religious affiliations, and
everyone comes together,
and we live in a society that tries
to point out our differences
and draw us apart,
and we are lucky enough
to be part of something
that draws people together.
- [Keith] Yo, this show got talking cats.
I am totally down.
- [Ned] Thank goodness
she finally let me in.
- Ned, we can read
the subtitles.
- [Ned] All right, sorry.
- [Zach and Eugene] You don't
have to read the subtitles.
- It's far away, though.
Her name's Oo-sah-jee.
- [Zach and Eugene] Usagi.
- Oh.
- This is literally a dream I've had
that a talking cat comes into my bedroom
and tells me I'm a pretty princess.
- [Eugene and Ned] Oh!
- [Ned] My god!
- [Eugene] Iconic
transformation sequence.
- I've seen this before.
- Yes, I know this.
- Oh, she's naked?
- [Ned] Yes, I'm--
- [Eugene] No, she's 14,
so she's--
- No, she was naked.
(arguing)
She's got break lights in her hair.
- I think half of Sailor Moon is actually
about them getting good grades.
If you don't have Asian parents,
you just have to know that
if you get bad grades--
- Yeah, but she's white.
These girls are white.
- Yeah, aren't they supposed
- to be Asian?
- [Eugene] They are Japanese.
Okay, they look white
in animation
- [Zach] They look white as
(beeps)
- They're obviously in Japan.
That's a whole conversation
- [Zach] She is white!
- in anime politics we
can talk about later,
but they are Japanese.
- [Zach] She's a blonde,
white girl.
- I know a Caucasian when I see one.
- Bubble power's the best power.
- Yeah.
- No, it's not, it's completely useless.
- Well, she's also
harnessing the power of soap.
- Oh, she fierce as (beeps).
- She kinda looks Japanese.
- Girl!
Yeah, she looks Japanese.
- Fire is way better than bubbles, though.
- I, I don't know about that.
- Sometimes, I get hurt,
and all I can do is
(funny grunting)
- Sailor Venus does have
that cute, bigass bow.
- Kinda like Ned's big old butt.
(laughing)
- All right.
Mercury has got that Google Glass, though.
(laughs)
- She goes into the rock signal.
She's like, "Yeah!"
- Yeah, she's like boom.
- They're like hard rockers.
- They are legit killing people.
There's so much action and like adventure
and the animation is so engaging,
even if it's geared towards girls,
I would watch this as a little boy.
- Oh, yeah.
- I love this show.
- Yeah, I like this one the best,
because
- [Zach] It is the coolest.
- [Keith] it's digestible.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- About friendship.
Also, they murder people.
- Power friendship.
- [All] Aww.
- I was gonna grab your dick!
- We all need each other.
- The best thing about cosplay
is there's just no rules.
So, whatever you guys
want is available to you.
- We wanna do Rule 63.
- Right.
- We want something that's
gonna be a crowd pleaser
at the masquerade,
- Obviously.
- and that we can do comedy
and inhabit the characters accurately.
- I think Sailor Moon
might be the way to go.
- So, now that we think
we have a good idea,
the hard part starts.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] On the next episode
of The Try Guys Try Cosplay,
will Zach ever recover
from an exhilarating battle
with hot glue?
Will Keith assume his
true form as a Titan?
Can Eugene be more Asian right now?
- [All] That's racist!
- White people.
- [Voiceover] Also, Ned's butt!
Stay tuned to find out what happens
when the Try Guys make
Sailor Moon costumes.
(reaction scream)
Oh, my god!
(relieved laughing)
That scares me every time.